[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
hey everybody its charlie big surprise
this morning we got brand new spider-man
to break down in a shiny new red and
black suit so everybody was freaking out
this morning because we've already seen
him in that black shield suit in all
those European boss fights with Mysterio
so we got to break this down there's a
new round of that spider-man ps4 game
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video I'll name a new winner at the
end of this if you didn't see it a
little while ago Tom Holland posted a
video saying thank you everybody the
spider-man far from home production was
leaving Venice they were officially done
filming in all their European locations
and they were going back to New York
City Tom Holland had a bit of a layover
for a couple days in Atlanta at Pinewood
Studios to shoot a couple of days on the
Avengers for reshoots while Mark Ruffalo
was making all that noise about
revealing the Avengers for title very
unsurprising that Marvel has Mark
Ruffalo running spoiler interference
while Tom Holland is trying to do
something a little bit secret but they
were still headed to New York City and
they're gonna be filming the rest of the
movie there till the beginning of
December so there's still a lot of big
scenes to film in New York City this is
just the beginning of it there at Penn
Station I'll talk about what's actually
going on in this scene but we got to
talk about the suit first because people
were a little bit confused about what it
was that they were going for it looks
like a modified version of the stark
tech suit because it has that black band
from the stark tech suit at the top but
all the blue panels are now solid black
and the emblem on his back is white
instead of red so what I think they're
actually going for is a homecoming stark
Tech version of the original black Steve
Ditko suit from amazing fantasy 15 in
the unused concept art that Brian Muir
Danang did for spider-man homecoming
there was a brief period when they
almost did a red black suit for
homecoming but they decided to go for
the more classic blue and red now the
funny thing about that is is that og
Steve Ditko yeah he did have the red
blue suit but when they first created
the character they originally intended
for the costume to be red and black it's
actually kind of funny how it wound up
being blue originally Steve Ditko draws
this version of spider-man it looks
black and looks a little bit blue but
that's just the highlights he added the
blue to the suit just to make it pop on
the page a little bit more
but what happened is that by the time
they got to amazing spider-man number
one dico had been drawing more and more
blue highlights on him so that
eventually people thought that the suit
looked more blue than it looked black
people really liked it the character
exploded in popularity because of the
stories they were telling so eventually
he just decided to make it blue so when
most people think of the original Steve
Ditko costume they're thinking about the
blue one but actually it started out
being black so in the way that original
Peter Parker wore the same suit and
Steve Ditko just colored it a little bit
differently I think that's what's going
on with this the original stark tech
suit that just colored a little bit
differently Steve Ditko passed away
recently - so Kevin Feige probably just
wants to add a little bit more of that
in this just to honor him as you can see
from the clip though what's actually
going on in this scene is this just the
two of them it's Peter in Michelle and
she seems like she's already been there
Peter swings in and waves hello at her
like totally casual oh hey by the way
remember me from all those boss battles
remember me from the Washington Monument
I am totally not stalking you and then
she just promptly climbs on him and they
swing away so they only shoot them
jumping off the rest of it they're gonna
film with a combination of green screen
and full-blown digital characters but
just because they're both super or
casual in this moment doesn't really
tell you what's going on in the scene
there been a couple big spider-man boss
battles at Penn Station in the comics
fun meta Easter Egg the venom movie just
came out there was a venom carnage fight
with spider-man at Penn Station from the
original arc that introduced the carnage
character then if you're a big daredevil
fan you probably know that season 3
which is dropping next week is actually
doing the born again storyline Penn
Station appeared during the born again
comic book so it's a really big New York
City Transit landmark it's very common
for people to go there so anything could
be happening in this scene none of the
other villains that are apparent during
the movie Mysterio the vulture scorpion
any of them are appearing anywhere in
this scene while they're filming but
that doesn't mean that this is the only
thing that's happening here they're just
shooting them if there was a big fight
going on here they could just be filming
that on a soundstage and they'll add it
later but it doesn't look like they're
in extreme danger like Michelle would
probably be freaking out if there was a
big boss fight going on it's a little
hard to tell whether this is happening
at the beginning of the movie
or if it's happening at the end of the
movie when they come back from Europe
but the thing here too is Michelle does
not look surprised at all by spider-man
so either she's starting to figure out
who Peter is or she's already been
through a couple of fights with him
because of all the Europe fights she
seems kind of intuitive but the whole
thing with her during homecoming was is
that is he was walking away she made it
seem like she didn't care but she was
really curious not in a bad way so it
just seems like she's gonna continue to
be suspicious of Peter Parker's sneaking
away all the time
imagine them walking through the Venice
canals where are you going Peter Parker
then they're at the carnival and Prague
where are you going Peter Parker there
was a giant boss fight where were you
last night oh you know couldn't sleep I
was just walking around everywhere so we
think part of the idea is that by the
end of this movie she'll figure out who
he is and they'll have a closer
relationship because they really didn't
even become friends during homecoming
like by the end of the movie she just
accepted the idea that she might become
friends with the debate group like I you
know I don't make friends real easy but
she accepted leadership so I think
that's them not going to that Tobey
Maguire or Andrew Garfield place where
you immediately put the love interest in
every single scene that the hero is in
in the very first movie they're just
building up towards that so it'll be
interesting to see what their dynamic is
like compared to other spider-man
pairings like the original Mary Jane
from Tobey Maguire or gwen stacy from
the andrew garfield era the really big
news today is that i'm allowed to post
my non-spoilery daredevil season 3
review i've seen the first half of the
season
it's amazing i'll talk all about it when
i post that review and then the titan
series just dropped on the DC streaming
service so depending on how much time I
have I'll probably do a video for that
Saturday morning because there's a whole
bunch of Batman related stuff that we
need to talk about as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you'll see
the videos when I post them no worries
congratulations karai you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details click here for that new Avengers
4 teaser and get a look at everybody's
brand-new shiny costumes and click here
for the teaser for the full black
spider-man far from home shield costume
thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see
tonight
[Music]
you